hey schön dass ihr dabei seid ZDF heute
live immer mehr Menschen suchen Asyl in
Europa vor allem hier bei uns in
Deutschland auch ohne geflüchtete
Ukrainerin ist die Zahl der Menschen die
Schutz suchen gestiegen seit Anfang des
Jahres wurden mehr als 100.000 Asyl
erstantrage gestellt das sind 78% mehr
als im Vorjahreszeitraum und Städte und
Gemeinden sagen sie seien an der
absoluten Kapazitätsgrenze wenn es darum
geht diese Menschen unterzubringen
schlagen Alarm und sie fordern auch
diskutieren über mehr Geld Länder und
Kommunen streiten mit dem Bund fordern
mehr Geld für Unterbringung Versorgung
und Integration und ob es eine Lösung in
diesem Streit gibt das ist heute Thema
unserer Sendung das wollen wir live mit
euch verfolgen denn in wenigen Minuten
soll der Gipfel die Ergebnisse des
Gipfels zwischen Bund und Ländern
verkündet werden bei einer
Pressekonferenz wir warten mit euch
gespannt schalten da also live drauf
sobald es losgeht und hoffentlich können
wir da auch Ergebnisse erwarten wir
beobachten das diskutierten mitstellt
Fragen direkt und ich versuche so viele
davon mit in diesem Stream hier rein zu
nehmen und zu beantworten beantworten zu
lassen von den ExpertInnen Experten die
wir bei uns in der Sendung haben bei uns
im Stream später auch ein Landrat aus
Hessen der uns über seine schwierige
Lage berichtet aber zuerst können wir
jetzt sprechen mit unserer
Korrespondentin im Hauptstadtstudio in
Berlin mit Nicole Diekmann die bei uns
ist hallo Nicole schön guten Abend
hallo Nicole ist da denn jetzt wirklich
eine Einigung zu erwarten es gab jetzt
auch Gerüchte vielleicht könnte es nur
eine Teil Einigung werden vielleicht
kommt es zu gar keiner was ist deine
Vermutung
schwer zu sagen also was wir mal
zusammenfassen können die letzten Tage
das war quasi eine Schlacht der Papiere
es ging ein Papier hin dann kam das
andere von der Gegenseite die Länder
taten sich zusammen dann antwortete der
bunter drauf das war auch die
Ausgangslage für die Gespräche heute 16
gegen 1 also 16 Bundesländer die sich
völlig einig waren gegen den Bund das
war also eine geschlossene Front die
sich da heute zusammengetan hat mit
einer klaren Forderung an dem Bund
nämlich mehr Geld mehr Unterstützung und
dadurch dass man vorher so erbittert
gestritten hat und auch dadurch dass man
heute eine Stunde später als geplant
angefangen hat überhaupt zusammen zu
sitzen im Kanzleramt haben sich die
Zeichen dafür verdichtet dass das sehr
sehr schwierig werden könnte und auf der
Pressekonferenz vor dem eigentlichen
Treffen mit dem Bund wollten sich sowohl
Hendrik wüst CDU Ministerpräsident
Nordrhein-Westfalen als auch Stefan weil
SPD
Ministerpräsident von Niedersachsen
nicht darauf festlegen ob man heute
wirklich das ganz dicke Brett durchbohrt
ob man womöglich tatsächlich auch ohne
Einigung daraus kommt was beide aber
sagten eigentlich nicht passieren dürfen
oder ob wie du es gerade schon gesagt
hast vielleicht erstmal nur eine
Teilreinigung präsentiert werden würde
auf der Pressekonferenz auf die wir
jetzt gerade warten genau wir sehen es
auch noch also die Anwesenden
Journalistinnen und Journalisten noch
tut sich nichts aber wie gesagt wir
gehen live rüber sobald es sich etwas
tut lass uns noch kurz sprechen also
eigentlich ist es ja so Aufnahme und
Betreuung von Schutzsuchenden das ist
Ländersache der Bund der hat jetzt im
Vorfeld auch immer wieder darauf
verwiesen dass er ja eigentlich schon so
viel gezahlt hat und die Länder die
fordern aber größtenteils auch ein
anderes System also wo automatisch mehr
Geld fließt wenn mehr Menschen dann zu
Ihnen ins Land kommen schauen wir uns
mal ganz kurz die Forderungen der Länder
genauer an wir müssen dazu jetzt eine
Karte vorbereitet haben genau da sehen
wir also eine Forderung ist der Bund der
soll die Kosten für Unterkunft und
Heizung für geflüchtete komplett
übernehmen und außerdem wollen sie die
Länder eine monatliche pro Kopfpauschale
nach dem Asylwerber leistungsgesetz und
auch bei integrations- und anderen
Folgekosten da soll der Bund mehr
übernehmen und siehst du da Aussichten
also für Erfolg für die Länder das das
wirklich was werden könnte das ist ja
schon sind ja auch mehrere Forderungen
die sie da dann auf den Tisch gelegt
haben
so ist es aber wie ich eben schon gesagt
habe also da war man sich selten einig
sowohl weil den ich eben schon genannt
habe MP von Niedersachsen als auch wüst
die eine gemeinsame Pressekonferenz vor
dem Treffen gegeben haben aber zum
Beispiel auch Markus Söder erzählst du
Ministerpräsident von Bayern der ja
gerne mal einen extra Kurs fährt alle 16
haben vor diesen Treffen in den Tagen
vor diesen Treffen gesagt wir brauchen
mehr Geld wenn man sich jetzt gestern
Abend das heute journal bei uns im ZDF
angeguckt hat und das Gespräch dass
Christian Sievers dort mit dem
Bundesfinanzminister mit Christian
Lindner geführt hat dann muss man davon
ausgehen dass diese Forderung nicht
erfüllt wird aber Christian Lindner sehr
klar und damit war auch er nicht alleine
im Vorfeld auch die SPD ist ihm da zur
Seite gesprungen SPD-Chefin Saskia esken
hat vorgestern noch gesagt es gibt eine
schönbremse die müssen wir einhalten so
das sind aber jetzt zwei von drei
ampelkoalitionspartnern da gibt's ja
auch noch die Grünen und aus deren rein
kam in den letzten Tagen andere Töne
Ricarda lang und auch um mit nuripur die
beiden Chefs der Grünen sagen
da haben die Länder da haben die
Kommunen schon einen Punkt wir müssen
damit Geld aushelfen also ich fasse das
mal zusammen die Länder sind sich einig
sie wollen mehr Geld der Bund sagt
eigentlich sehen wir das nicht so aber
es rumort mal wieder innerhalb der Ampel
und ich würde mal sagen die Tatsache
dass jetzt gleich eine Pressekonferenz
stattfinden soll die hatten alle auch
durchaus damit gerechnet dass es heute
noch viel viel später wird spricht ja
schon dafür dass es möglicherweise doch
eine Einigung Klammer auf Teil Klammer
zu Einigung geben könnte
du hast eben gerade auch den O-Ton
angesprochen das Interview das Christian
Lindner gestern im heute journal gegeben
hat während wir noch warten es sieht
aktuell noch ruhig aus ich habe immer
wieder einen Blick auf den Raum der
Pressekonferenz könnten wir auch noch
mal in eine Zusammenfassung schauen der
Ereignisse und da ist auch dann ein Teil
dieses Gesprächs eben mit drinne sollte
die Pressekonferenz vorher schon
losgehen würde ich es einfach
unterbrechen aber lasst uns doch
zusammen mal reinschauen in einen
Bericht von deiner Kollegin Nicole von
Christiane hübscher
als sie am Nachmittag im Kanzleramt
eintreffen da haben sie schon eine lange
Vorbesprechung ohne Kanzler hinter sich
geschlossen fordern die
ministerpräsidentinnen und Präsidenten
kurzfristig eine Milliarde mehr zur
flüchtlingsversorgung und besonders die
Union erhöht vorab den Druck auf Olaf
Scholz der Kanzler muss das Thema jetzt
zur Chefsache machen Verantwortung
übernehmen und Führung zeigen mehr als
100.000 Asylanträge wurden in
Deutschland seit Jahresbeginn gestellt
eine Zunahme um 78 Prozent im Vergleich
zum Vorjahreszeitraum und eben weil der
Zustrom so schwankt wollen die Länder
nicht einfach Pauschalzahlungen vom Bund
wir brauchen ein atmendes System wir
brauchen ein dynamisches System wir
brauchen ein System das vor allen Dingen
sich daran orientiert wie viel Menschen
sind denn eigentlich zu versorgen wie
groß aber der dezent mit Berlin ist das
hatte vorab schon der FDP Finanzminister
deutlich klar gemacht die
Bundesregierung ist nicht bereit ein
bestehendes Problem einfach nur mit Geld
zu lösen wir wollen das Problem nicht
finanzieren sondern wir wollen endlich
eine Veränderung in der
Migrationspolitik die bundesgrünen aber
stellen sich noch vor dem Treffen klar
auf die Seite der Länder formulieren in
einem eigenen zehn Punkteplan die
Erwartung dass der Bund gezielt mehr
finanzielle Verantwortung übernimmt als
bislang zugesagt wurde keine Einigkeit
also nicht innerhalb der Ampel nicht
zwischen Bund und Ländern dieser Gipfel
dürfte länger dauern
er hat auch länger gedauert wir warten
hier ja schon eine ganze Weile ich habe
eben gerade gesehen es werden schon
Fotos gemacht die Presse bringt sich in
Stellung lasst uns mal ganz kurz schon
mal rüberschwenken denn jetzt trifft
auch der Kanzler ein wir geben ab zur
Pressekonferenz und geben danach die
Analyse für euch gemeinsam mit Nicole
Dietmann und jetzt hören wir mal alle
zusammen zu
meine Herren meine Damen ich darf
herzlich willkommen heißen zur
Pressekonferenz nach der Zusammenkunft
der Regierungschefin und Regierungschefs
der Länder mit dem Bundeskanzler ich
begrüße hier natürlich den auf dem
Podium Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz den
Vorsitzenden der
Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
niedersachsenministerpräsident Stefan
weil und den nordrhein-westfälischen
Ministerpräsidenten Hendrik wüst und wir
informieren über die Ergebnisse der eben
beendeten Sitzung Herr Bundeskanzler
meine Damen und Herren unser Land steht
vor einer großen Herausforderung nicht
allein viele andere europäische Länder
teilen die Herausforderungen mit uns
aber es bleibt eine die wir eben auch
als Land zu bewältigen haben wir haben
viele Flüchtlinge aus der Ukraine
aufgenommen die in Deutschland
Unterkunft gefunden haben unterstützt
von unglaublichen Bürgern und Bürgern
viel ehrenamtliche Initiative heute sind
in Deutschland Vereine Million
ukrainische Flüchtlinge registriert das
ist die größte Zahl die einen
europäisches Land gegenwärtig vermeldet
und gleichzeitig steigt die Zahl
derjenigen die hier in Deutschland
Schutz suchen und aus anderen Ländern
kommen insofern bleibt es eine ganz
große Aufgabe die wir miteinander zu
leisten haben in einem föderalen Staat
mit den über 11.000 Gemeinden in unserem
Land mit den 16 Ländern und dem Bund und
das wird nur funktionieren wenn die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger die vielen
Helferinnen und Helfer aber eben auch
alle Ebenen unseres Staates Gemeinden
Länder und Bund eng miteinander
zusammenarbeiten und kooperieren ich
will deshalb ausdrücken an dieser Stelle
auch sagen wir wissen die Städte und
Gemeinden Leisten aus der ordentliches
sowohl die Länder als auch der Bund sind
sich darüber völlig im klaren und wir
sind sehr dankbar für das Engagement das
weit über die Verpflichtung hinausgeht
und immer auch von einem guten Herzen
getragen ist
das Treffen zur Frage wie wir mit dieser
Herausforderung weiter umgehen wollen
heute zwischen
den Ländern und dem der Bundesregierung
war ein sehr konstruktives und gutes
treffen wir haben es sehr sorgfältig
vorbereitet das auch aber es ist eben
auch in der Atmosphäre gut und
konstruktiv gewesen und ich finde dass
die Debatten und Gespräche die wir
hatten auch gut sind für unsere
Demokratie denn es geht ja darum Lösung
zu entwickeln miteinander Fragen zu
erörtern Vorschläge zu wegen und dann am
Ende gemeinsame Lösung zu entwickeln
große Aufgabe für der bestehen ist in
diesem Zusammenhang die irreguläre
Migration zu steuern und natürlich auch
zu begrenzen wir haben bereits in der
Vergangenheit eine ganze Reihe von
Gesetzen auf dem Weg brachte das besser
möglich machen auch durch rechtliche
Maßnahmen zu Beschleunigung von
Asylverfahren wir haben auch
Veränderungen vorgenommen die die
Ausweisung Abschiebehaft zum Beispiel
für Straftäter und Gefährder erleichtern
weitere Maßnahmen die wir in diesem
Zusammenhang vornehmen wollen sind
geplant und deshalb will ich einige
davon aufzählen über die wir hier auch
gesprochen und verständigt haben
zunächst mal wahrscheinlich auf die
lange sich die mittlere Sicht sogar in
kurzer Zeit wichtigste Veränderung wird
sein dass Deutschland jetzt ganz neue
Arten von migrationspartnerschaften
abschließen wird wir werden uns mit
anderen Ländern verständigen über die
Möglichkeit der Erleichterung des
Fachkräfte Zuges aus diesen Ländern aber
im Gegenzug eben auch sehr klare
Vereinbarung abschließen über die
Rücknahme der eigenen Staatsbürger wenn
Sie hier nicht bleiben können aus den
verschiedenen Gründen aber zum Beispiel
auch deshalb weil sie nicht erfolgreich
sich hier um zum Beispiel Asyl bemüht
haben damit das gut und effektiv und
effizient gelingt haben wir auch ein
Sonderbeauftragten Joachim Stand ist
dafür jetzt von der Bundesregierung
benannt und hat sich vielleicht beherzt
an seine Arbeit gemacht das wird als
Vorhaben von Bund und den Ländern
gemeinsam geteilt und wird bei der
gemeinsame Herausforderung wie kriegen
wir jemanden der ausreisepflichtiges oft
tatsächlich dazu dass er wieder in
seinen Heimatland zurückkehrt sehr
helfen
wir sind uns auch einig darüber dass es
notwendig ist dass wir den Schutz der
EU-Außengrenzen weiter voranbringen das
ist etwas was nicht in Deutschland
stattfindet denn Deutschland nicht
mitten in Europa ist umgeben von vielen
anderen europäischen
Mitgliedsstaaten unserer Union und ist
deshalb ein Land das interessiert ist an
einem effizienten Grenzschutz der aber
anderswo stattfindet und deshalb sind
wir unterstützen tätig mit unseren
eigenen Beamten und Beamten deshalb und
unterstützen wir das Vorhaben der
Europäischen Union diese Länder bei der
Errichtung von grenzschutzstrukturen zu
unterstützen und natürlich geht es auch
darum dass wir an der Grenze bessere
Möglichkeiten haben auf einen
Anerkennungsverfahren direkt an den
EU-Außengrenzen durchzuführen
für uns ist auch wichtig dass wir unser
eigenen Grenzen gut bewachen das können
wir auch wir haben zum Beispiel in der
binnengrenze zu Österreich die
Möglichkeit des Grenzschutzes
fortgesetzt und wir werden Lage abhängig
auch bei weiteren an einer Staaten
ähnliche Schritte ergreifen bzw die
Intensivierung von schleierfahnen
vorzunehmen die werden den deutschen
Grenzen ohnehin organisieren
was wir auf brauchen sind natürlich alle
Möglichkeiten Asylverfahren zu
beschleunigen denn es ist sowohl für
diejenigen die hier Schutz suchen
wichtig schnell zu wissen woran Sie sind
als auch für uns wichtig dass durch ein
schnelles und zügiges verfahren wir auch
dann entscheiden können wer bleiben soll
weil der Schutz gewährt werden soll und
wer gehen muss und deshalb auch
von uns dazu bewegt werden kann das zu
tun wir werden deshalb ein
beschleunigtes Asylverfahren wie wir das
in anderen Fällen auch haben zum
Beispiel für solche Länder die eine
eu-beitrittsperspektive haben wie
Georgien und Moldau auf dem Weg bringen
wichtig ist natürlich immer dann wenn
eine Ausreisepflicht besteht dass sie
auch durchgesetzt wird und deshalb haben
wir uns über ganz verschiedene Punkte
unterhalten die hier nur exemplarisch
aufgezählt werden sollen aber die eine
große Rolle spielen die Bundespolizei
wird zum Beispiel dann wenn sie in ihre
eigenen Amtstätigkeit ausreisepflichtige
aufgreift die Möglichkeit haben durch
eine ständige Erreichbarkeit der Länder
auch zu organisieren dass diese
ausreisepflichtigen dann auch
tatsächlich dazu gebracht werden können
wir werden auch die
Informationsverfahren zwischen
Justizbehörden und Ausländerbehörden zum
Beispiel Verfahren weiter verbessern das
sind rechtliche Veränderungen die
notwendig sind aber praktische
Tätigkeiten der Länder
was wir brauchen sind natürlich genügend
abschiebehaftplätze und gewahrsamsplätze
aber natürlich muss es auch so sein dass
wir
die Möglichkeit haben diese Haft auch
anzuordnen auch wenn neue Anträge
gestellt werden zum Beispiel das
Einreise und Aufenthaltsverbote
eigenständige Haftgründe keinen sein
können das Beschwerden
von Behörden gegen abgelehnte
haftanträge vorgenommen werden können
wir haben uns vorgenommen das Ausreise
Gewahrsam zu verlängern von heute 10 auf
28 Tagen und der
Gemeinschaftsunterkünften die ja doch
auf der großen sind wollen wir die
Möglichkeit schaffen dass man nicht nur
an der einen Stelle wo jemand ein Zimmer
hatte gucken kann ob sich jemand den wir
antreffen wollen dort befindet und auch
anderen Ort in der Unterkunft
gleichzeitig wollen wir viele
Präzisierung vornehmen was zum Beispiel
widersprochen Anklage gegen 31 und
offenheitsverbote betrifft und
wohnsitzauflagen alles um dafür Sorge zu
tragen dass die Verfahren schneller und
zügiger durchgeführt werden können das
gilt auch bei Abstimmungen im Rahmen von
strafrechtlichen Ermittlungsverfahren
Europa hat eine Verständigung darüber
dass diejenigen die anderswo bereits
registriert worden sind dort ihr
asylschutzverfahren durchführen müssen
wenn dann trotzdem sich betreffende nach
Deutschland begeben haben dann ist es
erforderlich dass ein kurzer Zeit der
entsprechende rückübernahmeantrag
gestellt wird sechs Monate ist das
gegenwärtige europäische Regime und wir
haben uns darauf verständigt dass das
auch in Zukunft in dieser
Geschwindigkeit von den zuständigen
Ausländerbehörden in den Ländern
vorgenommen werden wird für uns ist
ebenfalls wichtig dass wir im Rahmen
dieser Dublin drei Verfahren eine große
Reform des europäischen analsystems
hinbekommen die auch sicherstellen dass
mehr Länder diejenigen die
zurückgenommen werden müssen auch
zurücknehmen eine wichtige
Herausforderung genauso viel viele
andere Formen die wir machen wollen
was wir brauchen ist eine moderne
Verwaltung deshalb haben wir uns auch
für ständig darüber die Digitalisierung
der Ausländerbehörden voranzutreiben in
kürzester Zeit soll die gesamten
Ausländerbehörden vollständig digital
arbeiten Ausländer Akten sollen
elektronisch ausgetauscht werden können
und es soll ein enger Austausch mit dem
Ausländer Zentralregister organisiert
werden das werden wir auch jetzt
miteinander organisieren und das eine
der Verständigung dass wir das in kurzer
zügiger Turm machen wollen wir wollen
dafür Sorge tragen dass unser Ausländer
Zentralregister die zentrale
behördenübergreifende Plattform für den
Austausch der notwendigen Informationen
gibt wir wollen unsere Wohnraum kümmern
und auch die Erleichterung die wir zum
Beispiel bei 14 15 für Neubau Maßnahmen
festgelegt haben weiter fortführen und
auch entsprechend mit den Mitteln und
bitte der Beamer der bundesanstaltungen
weiterhelfen
sie sehen ein sehr umfassendes sehr
klares Paket von Maßnahmen die jetzt auf
dem Weg gebracht werden um dafür zu
sorgen dass Deutschland effizient
handelt dass es zügig und schnell
handelt dass wir koordiniert agieren
können damit wir gewährleisten können
dass wir denjenigen schutzgewehren
können die Schutz in Deutschland
benötigen und uns auch humanitäres
Asylrecht auf in Anspruch nehmen sollen
das wäre gleichzeitig gewährleisten
können dass diejenigen die nicht bleiben
können wieder zurückkehren und dass das
bis hin zur Abschiebung und zu den
verbreitungsverfahren bisschen zur
Digitalisierung gelingt einschließlich
solche Reformen wie das was wir im
Hinblick auf Georgien umwälder uns
vorgenommen haben
wir haben selbstverständlich auch über
Finanzmittel unterhalten wie auch nicht
das glaube ich ist bei einer so großen
gemeinsamen Aufgabe von bundländern und
Gemeinden auch unverzichtbar und deshalb
haben wir gemeinsam noch einmal
betrachtet dass es schon sehr umfassende
Mittel sind die wir aufwenden der Bund
hat in engeren Sinne etwa 15 Milliarden
Euro an Kosten die ja für
transferzahlung zum Beispiel im Rahmen
des Bürgergeldes für Flüchtlinge auf den
Weg bringt und finanziert das sind
ähnliche Aufwendungen die sich bei den
Ländern finden und dass wir das
gemeinsam für uns so festgehalten haben
das halte ich für ein ganz ganz großen
Fortschritt das ist etwas was wir
miteinander so sehen natürlich geht es
darum was man auch sonst noch tun kann
unsere Verständigung heute ist dass der
Bund zusätzlich zu den pauschalen
Mitteln die er bereitstellt eine weitere
Milliarde mobilisiert damit sowohl die
eine Aufgabe der Digitalisierung der
Ausländerbehörden gestützt werden kann
als auch Kommunen besser
unterstützt werden können bei ihrer
schwierigen und umfassenden Aufgaben wir
haben uns darüber hinaus verständigt
dass wir im November wenn wir erneut in
einer regulären kommt Zusammenkunft uns
treffen als Regierungschefin
Regierungschefs der Länder und als mit
mir dass wir dann die Frage erörtern wie
wir längerfristig dieses System
vielleicht weiterentwickeln können da
gibt es unterschiedliche Vorstellungen
aber das ist ja kein Grund sich der
Sache nicht zuzuwenden wir werden das
aber eine kleine effiziente
Arbeitsgruppe einrichten die auch
zwischendurch berichten wird über ihre
Arbeit um zu gucken was wir da
miteinander vielleicht an guter
Erkenntnis und Idee entwickeln können
ich glaube das ist eine gute Kombination
eine konkrete Hilfe für dieses Jahr um
die Herausforderung besser bewältigen zu
können und gleichzeitig etwas das dazu
beiträgt dass wir uns gemeinsam Gedanken
über die zukünftige Gestaltung machen
meine Damen und Herren ich finde das ist
ein guter Tag des deutschen Föderalismus
den wir heute haben weil er zeigt dass
wir wenn wir uns zusammenraufen müssen
wir das auch tun dass wir eine Aufgabe
von der wir alle gemeinsam stehen und
die wir gut bewältigen müssen wir auch
genug bewältigen wollen und zwar
miteinander und nicht gegeneinander ich
möchte nämlich denkt deshalb auch bei
den
Ministerpräsidenten und
Ministerpräsident der Ländern beim Wüste
und vielen anderen die dort waren sehr
bedanken das ist alles heute eine
möglich gewesen weil wir alle gemeinsam
ein Ergebnis gewollt haben und das haben
wir auch erreicht also eine gute
Nachricht
vielen Dank
das waren die schwierigen Gespräche die
alle im Vorfeld erwartet hatten
sie wissen dass wir uns zwischen Bund
und Ländern ich sag mal ein lebhaften
Meinungsaustausch im Vorfeld geliefert
hatten und dann ist ja auch zum Ausdruck
gekommen dass es uns beiden um sehr
ernste Themen geht
ich bin wirklich froh darüber dass wir
es geschafft haben in vielen Stunden und
bereits in der Vorarbeit im gestrigen
Tage uns auf eine gemeinsame Position zu
verständigen teilweise auch uns zusammen
zu raufen und auch dort wo wir noch
nicht einer Meinung sind daraus kann
hier zu machen aber ein Prozess zu
beschreiben wie wir zu einer gemeinsamen
Meinung gelangen können
das ist deswegen wichtig weil die Themen
ringsum Flucht und Asyl
zu den schwierigsten
gesellschaftspolitischen Themen
überhaupt gehört und wir sind uns bunt
und Länder der gemeinsamen Verantwortung
bewusst und wir wissen das Bürgerinnen
und Bürger von uns Lösungen erwarten und
nicht in erster Linie Streit und das ist
prägend über unsere Zusammenarbeit
insofern war das heute eine
ausgesprochen gute Zusammenkunft ich
sag's mal ganz offen besser als sich das
noch vor ein oder vor zwei Tagen für
Möglichkeiten hätte herzlichen Dank
dafür
im Mittelpunkt stand natürlich die Frage
der finanziellen Lastenverteilung und da
will ich sagen dass ich verstehe dass
der Bund Wert darauf legt dass seine
erheblichen Anstrengung auch als solche
wahrgenommen werden das ist richtig und
dass ich verstehe dass wenn man
Schwierigkeiten hat wirklich zu einem
allseits zufriedenstellenden Haushalt zu
gelangen dann an dieser Stelle auch
entsprechend restriktiv sein muss das
kann ich schon deswegen verstehen weil
das in den Ländern überhaupt nicht
anders ist sondern ganz genau so
dennoch sehen wir als Länder natürlich
vor allen Dingen auch die
Herausforderung für die Kommunen die
nämlich die Last größtenteils zu tragen
haben und wir haben im Vorfeld mit den
kommunalen Spitzenverbänden intensiv
gesprochen wir wissen aus eigener
Erfahrung durch die Gespräche mit den
Kommunen in unseren Ländern wie groß
dort die Anstrengung ist und das
tatsächlich sehr genau darauf achten
wird ob die Kommunen sich in einer
zugespitzen Situation vom Staat
unterstützt fühlen können von diesem
Hintergrund begrüße ich sehr die
Initiative des Bundes durch eine
zusätzliche Milliarde Euro für das Jahr
2023 dieses notwendige Signal zu geben
und ich bin sehr sicher das wird auch in
diesem Sinne wahrgenommen werden
diese Milliarde ist wichtig sie löst
allerdings natürlich noch nicht die
Grundsatzfrage wie können wir eigentlich
uns vorstellen dass es in Zukunft mit
der Finanzierung von flüchtlingslasten
insbesondere mit der Unterstützung von
Kommunen ausschaut und da sind wir nicht
so weit gekommen dass wir sagen könnten
wir hätten heute die gleiche Position
zur unterschiedlich sind dafür die
Ausgangsposition aber wir sind uns einig
darüber es ist eine Daueraufgabe und wir
sind uns einig drüber wir müssen zu
einem gemeinsamen Blick kommen
jedenfalls wollen wir uns sehr dafür
anstrengen und wir haben keinen
unverbindlichen Arbeitskreis bilden
wollen sondern erwarten dass dort sehr
ergebnisorientiert gearbeitet wird und
dass wir auf dieser Grundlage dann
hoffentlich ein gemeinsam eine
gemeinsame Position entwickelt haben
können wenn nicht dann haben wir aber
mindestens gegenseitig jede Menge
Verständnis dafür entwickelt warum die
jeweils andere sehr seitlich sich da
entsprechend aufstellt und lassen Sie
mich so sagen die Kommunen haben von den
Ländern so wie es die Verfassung auch
vorsieht erwartet dass wir als ihre
Sachwalter bei diesen Gesprächen in
Berlin auftreten und zu haben wir uns
aufgestellt so sind wir vorgegangen
das ist glaube ich etwas was auch für
die Kommunen ebenfalls wichtig ist wir
haben hier Länder für die Kommunen
gekämpft und wir werden das auch weiter
tun wenn sie sich das Papier durchlesen
die Diskussion ist eben nicht zu Ende
sondern sie wird sehr vertieft
fortgesetzt werden und ich bin nach den
Erfahrungen des heutigen Tages wirklich
zuversichtlich dass wir an dieser Stelle
auch zu Ergebnissen kommen was immer an
dieser Stelle herauskommen wird
die eigentlichen Wurzeln des Problems
sind natürlich damit nicht lösbar wir
haben es mit einer hohen Migration zu
tun und wir sehen dass die Akzeptanz in
der Bevölkerung tatsächlich nicht so ist
wie man sich das in vielen Fällen
wünschen möchte aber das ist auch gut
erklärlich und wir sehen vor allen
Dingen auch dass die Probleme ja nicht
vorbei sind sondern dass wir
beispielsweise nicht wissen wie sich die
Zahl der asylbewerbenden in diesem Jahr
noch entwickeln wird ob die Zunahme die
wir in den ersten Monaten erlebt haben
sich sofort setzt
deswegen unterstützen wir als Länder
ausdrücklich die europapolitischen
Initiativen die die Bundesregierung
vorhat Richtung Grenzsicherung Richtung
grenzdurchführung von Asylverfahren bei
Grenzübertritt aber auch die Absicht zu
wirksamen Rücknahmeabkommen zu gelangen
mit Staaten die ihre Bürgerinnen und
Bürger schlichtweg nicht zurücknehmen
ein seit Jahren ungelöstes Problem wir
wissen das kann die Bundesregierung
nicht alleine lösen aber wir wünschen
dir wirklich viel Erfolg dabei mit ihren
völlig berechtigten Vorstellungen auch
Verbündete auf der europäischen Ebene zu
gewinnen und auf diese Art und Weise
echte Fortschritte zu erzielen in
Deutschland selber
haben wir ebenfalls auf einer Reihe von
gemeinsamen Positionen einigen können
gelegentlich wird jetzt die Frage
gestellt ob das eine asylwinde sei was
jetzt passiert nein das ist es nicht
aber es ist der notwendige Antrieb dass
die bestehenden Gesetze umgesetzt werden
dass Menschen die kein Bleiberecht in
Deutschland haben dann Deutschland auch
verlassen müssen und dass die Verfahren
nach Möglichkeit schnell sind und
effektiv sind das tun wir insbesondere
auch deswegen weil damit auch die
Akzeptanz gestärkt wird für den für das
Bleiberecht derjenigen die ein
Schutzrecht haben und da soll man sich
nicht täuschen das ist eine Mehrheit
derjenigen die derzeit zu uns kommen
aber gerade weil es so ist sind wir umso
mehr darauf angewiesen auch tatsächlich
zu differenzieren und wir halten die
Vorschläge die in dieser Hinsicht von
der Bundesregierung entwickelt worden
sind fast durchgängig für gut und auch
für realisierbar und unterstützen Sie
gerne und deswegen ist auch insofern
Verschluss den wir heute gefasst haben
von Substanz kurz gesagt das war aus
meiner Sicht die Mühe wert und ich freue
mich heute Abend vor allen Dingen dass
wir feststellen können dass auch in
schwierigen Situationen Bund und Länder
ein weiteres Mal den Nachweis geliefert
haben dass sie gemeinsam zu nicht nur zu
Diskussionen sondern auch zu Lösungen in
der Lage sind und dass wir auch eine
gemeinsame Verantwortung wahrnehmen
insofern hoffe ich dass dieses nicht nur
ein guter Abend für viele schwierige
Themen von Flucht und Asyl in
Deutschland sind ist sondern das ist
auch ein guter Abend für den
Föderalismus gewesen ist ich empfinde es
jedenfalls
vielen Dank als drittes Hendrik grüßt ja
vielen Dank große gesellschaftliche
Herausforderungen brauchen immer eine
gemeinsame Kraftanstrengung aller
politischen Ebenen das kennen wir schon
aus vielen gemeinsamen Besprechungen in
dieser Runde deshalb stehen beim Thema
Flüchtlinge bundländer und Kommunen
wieder gemeinsam mit einer Verantwortung
unsere Städte Kreise Gemeinden leisten
derzeit wieder herausragendes Länder vor
allen Dingen aber die Kommunen tragen im
praktischen Leben auch bei diesem Thema
die Hauptlast im Bereich Meditation bei
Aufnahme Unterbringung Integration
Beschulung und Betreuung wir haben zu
Beginn der Woche im Kreis der
Ministerpräsident ein sehr intensiven
Austausch mit den kommunalen
Spitzenverbänden gehabt das sind ja dann
nicht nur Verbandsvertreter sondern auch
Praktiker die aus ihrem Leben da täglich
berichten und dabei ist erneut die
starke Forderung der Kommunen starke
Forderung der Kommunen wie sie gefordert
sind in dem Sinne deutlich geworden und
es wird auch ihre Forderungen noch mal
klar unterstrichen worden die sie Blick
auf die Beratung am heutigen Teil
insbesondere an den Bund richten wir
haben heute einen ersten Schritt gemacht
und wir haben einen Fahrplan mit einem
Zwischenbericht im Juni und eine
Entscheidung im November verabredet
mehr war eben nicht drin das muss man
heute so klar sagen wir haben bei der
zentralen Frage eine stärkeren
dauerhaften finanziellen Unterstützung
der Kommunen durch den Bund heute noch
keine hausweite Antwort erhalten aber
eben ein Einstieg in diesen Fahrplan ich
will ausdrücklich anerkennen
wie der Bund sich vergleichbar mit den
Ländern schon heute
enorm engagiert bei dem ganzen
Themenbereich der zentrale Punkt ist
aber dass die Kommunen uns klar mit auf
den Weg gegeben haben Verlässlichkeit
und Planbarkeit
herzustellen Unterbringung Versorgung
und vor allem Integration sind eben
daueraufgaben von Bund Ländern und
Kommunen darin sind für uns einig und
das haben wir heute festgestellt ich
bedanke mich ausdrücklich beim Bund
dafür dass wir das ich glaube in dieser
Klarheit in dieser Form in den Beschluss
jedenfalls erstmals so klar festgestellt
haben Daueraufgabe aus Sicht der Länder
muss das auch heißen dass es dann
stärker
dauerhafte Finanzierung für die Kommunen
gibt bis zum Jahr 21 gab es eine
flüchtlingsfinanzierung auch für den
Bereich Asyl die gleichzeitig dynamisch
auf Flüchtlingszahlen reagieren konnte
das sogenannte vier Säulen Modell das
gibt es nicht mehr das wurde von der
Bundesregierung beendet Länder und
Kommunen wollen wieder ein dauerhaftes
System dass ich an veränderten
Flüchtlingszahlen eben auch im Bereich
Asyl anpasst
es darf bei dem Thema nach unserer
festen Überzeugung kein wiederkehrendes
politisches falschen geben sondern Kleid
und Verlässlichkeit auch da sind wir uns
einig die Kommunen fordern vor allem
dass der Bund die Kosten der Unterkunft
vollständig übernimmt und zwar dauerhaft
da war heute noch keine Lösung möglich
da hätten wir uns heute eine Lösung
gewünscht auch über das Jahr 2023 hinaus
aber wir haben jetzt eben ein klares
Verfahren mit dem Zwischenschritt auch
im Juni
um unseren Kommunen
möglichst zügig Planungssicherheit zu
geben ohne immer wieder über dieses
Thema langwierig diskutieren zu müssen
das ist gut aber da liegt auch noch eine
Menge Arbeit vor uns ich will fair
anerkennen dass der Bund eine
zusätzliche Milliarde bereitstellt und
mich dafür ausdrücklich bedanken das
sind schwierige Zeiten für alle
staatlichen Ebenen was die Haushalte
angeht insofern ist eine Milliarde hier
wirklich fair anzuerkennen die Länder
werden diese Milliarde
zur Entlastung der Kommunen und zur
Digitalisierung der Ausländerbehörden
nutzen das ist hilfreich aber für die
Kommunen ist das noch nicht ausreichend
weil es eben eine Einmalzahlung ist wenn
wir alle gemeinsam den Flüchtlingen den
Menschen die zu uns kommen wir reden
über Zahlen über Paragraphen über
staatliche Ebene wir reden vor allem
aber immer dabei über Menschen wenn wir
den gerecht werden kommen die Schutz
suchen Hilfe suchen bei uns dann müssen
wir auf allen Ebenen unserer
Verantwortung gerecht werden wer
entscheidet der muss auch Verantwortung
übernehmen das ist eine klare Regel und
deswegen gilt da der Bund hat
überwiegenden Einfluss in die ganz
sicher jedenfalls im Verhältnis zu
Kommunen und Ländern Überzug zu
entscheiden und muss deswegen auch in
Zukunft finanzielle Verantwortung
übernehmen die sich am fluchtgeschehen
orientiert wir sind uns einig Bund
Länder und Kommunen wollen Humanität in
der
Flüchtlingspolitik dafür müssen die
Voraussetzungen geschaffen eine faire
verlässliche Finanzierung und zweitens
eine bessere Steuerung und Ordnung der
Migration beim Thema Steuerung und
Ordnung haben wir einiges vereinbart was
in die richtige Richtung geht wir sehen
uns einig irreguläre Migration muss
spürbar reduziert werden dazu brauchen
wir ein effektives
rückführungsmanagement für diejenigen
die kein Bleiberecht haben es geht immer
darum denjenigen gut gerecht werden zu
können die wirklich unsere Hilfe
brauchen die anderen müssen eben auch
dann zurückkehren der Bund arbeitet
daran weitere Abkommen mit
Herkunftsstaaten abzuschließen um die
Rückführung zu verbessern außerdem
wollen Bund Länder gemeinsam die
Asylverfahren beschleunigen und wir
brauchen endlich eine gemeinsame
solidarische humanitäre europäische
Flüchtlingspolitik Bundesregierung hat
angekündigt sich dafür einzusetzen dass
sie notwendige Reformen die früher 24 in
Europa vereinbart werden die Länder
unterstützen Sie dabei
ausdrücklich es ist wichtig dass das
kommt dass wir dann nachfolgend
sicherlich seine Wirkung entfalten
brauchen aber aus Sicht der Kommunen
schnelle spürbare Entlastung auch schon
vorher deswegen werden wir uns im
weiteren Prozess weiter als Länder auch
als Anwalt der Kommunen verstehen und
uns entsprechend einbringen bin dankbar
für die
konstruktiven Beratung viel am
Verständnis gearbeitet für die jeweils
andere Position das ist gut das muss
auch so sein bei so einem sensiblen
Thema dass man sich ein Stück weit Zeit
nimmt dafür dem anderen seine Position
zu erklären und auch zuzuhören was die
Position des anderen ist das haben wir
getan und wenn wir in dem Geist jetzt
den verabredeten Prozess gestalten dann
kommen ein gutes Ergebnis dabei raus
vielen Dank
so meine Damen und Herren ich habe
bereits einige Fragen Meldungen notiert
die erste Frage hier vorne Markus Decker
vom Handy
ja der Schlachtenlärm war ja in den
letzten Tagen doch erheblicher weil sie
haben das auch angedeutet jetzt ist
alles was wir hier hören und was wir aus
der Sitzung gehört haben alles doch sehr
schädlich friedlich da fragt man sich
warum nicht gleich so
und dann habe ich noch eine
Lernfrage man hat hier eben gesehen dass
auch Harbeck unter anderem an der
Sitzung teilgenommen hat und auch Herr
Lauterbach da würde mich interessieren
warum
also zunächst mal wir sind alle ganz
froh dass wir uns so gut
zusammengefunden haben und auch nicht
miteinander beraten haben was übrigens
auch im Vorfeld schon der Fall war da
hat es noch viele intensive stundenlange
Gespräche gegeben wo auch viele von
unseren
Mitarbeiter und Mitarbeitern sich
beteiligt haben so dass das eigentlich
zu erwarten war dass wir hier gut
wegkommen aber soll den Tag nicht vor
dem Abend loben und da ist jetzt der
Abend also können wir ihn loben also das
ist so ungefähr die Situation aber wenn
man mich hätte fragen sollen heute
Morgen wie es ausgeht hätte ich gesagt
so und insofern bin ich natürlich
besonders zufrieden das zweite ist wir
haben geguckt dass bei den
bundesministerinnen und Bundesministern
soweit sie verfügbar sind die dabei sind
die jeweils in den Ressort auch mit
Fragestellungen der Migration was zu tun
haben da gibt es ja verschiedenste
Aspekte und das ist dann jeweils der
Grund gewesen
als nächstes ist von ARD
herzlichen Dank zum einen sie haben es
ja eben auch schon angedeutet dass sie
die rückführungsmöglichkeiten die
beschleunigten rückführungsmöglichkeiten
nach
Georgien unter anderem dass sie das dass
sie dafür auch ein Gesetzesvorschlag
beschleunigst vorlegen wollen nach
Artikel 16A Absatz 3 ist das die
Ausweitung der sicheren Herkunftsländern
und ist das dann auch eben geeint mit
ihrem Koalitionspartner den Grünen die
eigentlich die Ausweitung sichere
Herkunftsländer ablehnen und an die
Länder würde mich interessieren die
Frage sie hatten heute Nachmittag gerade
Sie Herr Wüste doch eher ähm etwas
verhalten geklungen bei einem Kompromiss
der ihm eine Einmalzahlung wie eben hier
diese eine Milliarde angeht wie stehen
sie denn jetzt dazu also ist dann das
Ergebnis für sie tatsächlich dann kein
Ergebnis sowieso heute Nachmittag gesagt
haben
sie sicher wir haben hier einmal
getroffen die ich natürlich sorgfältig
vorgesprochen und vorbereitet habe und
jetzt gehen die Aufträge raus dass die
zuständigen Ministerinnen und Minister
die Gesetze vorbereiten dann werden sie
im Bundeskabinett beschlossen den
Bundestag zugeleitet und dann werden wir
in diesem Jahr auch die Gesetzgebung
bellen
wir haben ja einen Prozess vereinbart
und daran sehen wir sehen sie dass wir
an der einstelle heute kein Ergebnis
haben sonst hätten wir kein Prozess
vereinbaren müssen das liegt in der
Natur der Sache
beide Herren rechts von mir haben das
Wort zusammengerauft verwendet deshalb
nicht ich verwendet sondern bei der
Herren rechts von mir und diese
zusammenraufen besteht eben dann darin
dass man wenn man an diesem Tage nicht
zu einem Ergebnis kommt wie wir es uns
gewünscht haben für die Kommunen eine
dauerhafte verlässliche und Stefan weil
immer zurecht sagt atmende Lösung dass
wir dann uns verabreden an dem Thema zu
arbeiten und das ist dann auch das Gute
dass man nicht auseinander geht und sagt
Hammer nichts
sondern in Anerkennung der Leistung der
Kommunen und auch in Erwartungen dass
der Aufwand für die Kommunen nicht
kleiner wird in den nächsten Monaten
sagt okay wir kommen heute nicht
zueinander aber wir arbeiten dran in den
nächsten Wochen und dann ist es ein
Ergebnis mit dem man bei den Differenzen
in der Ausgangsposition heute abend
leben kann aber es muss ein Ergebnis
geben klar wir haben uns verabredet zu
arbeiten
ich hätte heute morgen anders als der
Bundeskanzler noch nicht darauf gewettet
dass wir so auseinander gehen ich hätte
mir auch vorstellen können dass wir
schlichtweg vorstellen
zusammenfassen wir sind uns uneinig und
das war's das ist genau nicht geschehen
und das ist für mich ein echter
Fortschritt
die Themen um die es geht sind schwer in
jeder Hinsicht aber der Umstand dass wir
eben jetzt nicht aufhören es uns schwer
zu machen sondern wenn man so will in
dieser Frage gerade erst damit anfangen
mit einem sehr ernst gemeinten
Arbeitsprozess das ist ein stark es
Zeichen und ich kann für die Länder
sagen dass wir das wirklich auch
ausgesprochen ernst nehmen und dass die
Erfahrung des heutigen Tages erstmal
zuversichtlich ansberg gehen lässt also
es ist nicht so dass in dieser Frage
nichts erreicht worden wäre das hätte
man sich heute morgen ganz anders
vorstellen können
Andreas Rink heute morgen noch ganz
anders vorgestellt jetzt sechs Stunden
später ist er da das ist der Beschluss
ihr habt ihn gehört eben gerade in der
Pressekonferenz was verkündet wurde die
Pressekonferenz von Bund und Ländern
fassen wir noch einmal kurz zusammen in
Sachen Geld das soll es geben eine
Milliarde zusätzlich für die Kosten die
mit der Unterbringung von geflüchteten
für die Länder entstehen also eine
Milliarde zusätzlich in 2023 aber eine
Grundsatzentscheidung über die Kosten
über die weiteren Kosten die es nicht
gefallen und wir wollen das ganze jetzt
analysieren kommen zu euren Fragen
deswegen stellt die sehr gerne bei mir
für die Analyse jetzt auch wieder Nicole
Diekmann Hauptstadtstudio
Korrespondentin in Berlin Nicole die
erste Frage kommt direkt bei uns aus dem
Stream von lucious er oder sie fragt
sich und was wurde jetzt genau
weltbewegendes beschlossen die eine
Milliarde Steuergelder die umverteilt
werden oder ist man einfach froh dass
man überhaupt miteinander geredet hat
was würdest du sagen
genau ich würde sagen letzteres ich habe
auch gerade gedacht als Niedersachsen
Ministerpräsident Stefan weil sagte na
ja ich hätte mir im Vorfeld ehrlich
gesagt auch vorstellen können dass ihr
heute gar nichts beschlossen wird
vielleicht haben auch unsere Zuschauer
noch diesen
Koalitionsausschuss diesen Marathon
Ausschuss von 30 Stunden im Gedächtnis
wir hier in Berlin im Hauptstadtstudio
haben dass zumindest und die wieder
heute zusammen saßen haben das womöglich
auch vielleicht haben sich da die
Maßstäbe ein bisschen verschoben und man
ist schon man muss das so sagen mit
einem so kleinen gemeinsamen Nenner wie
denen die die drei der gerade
präsentiert haben zufrieden das ist mehr
als nicht ja und das wurde auch
natürlich aufgezählt jenseits der Kosten
gibt es natürlich auch noch andere Dinge
auf die man sich verständigt hat aber da
war vieles dabei was man natürlich so
oder so ähnlich auch schon gehört hat
also Olaf Scholz der Bundeskanzler hatte
referiert Asylverfahren sollten
beschleunigt werden die Ausländer
Behörden sollen digitaler werden das
wäre natürlich wünschenswert 2023
ansonsten ging es darum ihr reguläre
Migration zu stoppen und zu begrenzen
also das wurde wiederholt war da sonst
noch irgendetwas Neues für dich dabei
irgendwas weltbewegendes
naja also zwei drei Punkte die er
genannt hat die auch im Vorfeld dieser
Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz ich hatte
das ja schon vor dieser PK gerade
angesprochen in den Papieren die hier in
den letzten Tagen durch Berlin
gegeistert sind thematisiert wurde es
soll eine härtere Gangart geben vor
allem bei den Abschiebungen
Scholz hat er eben ein paar Punkte
genannt so soll zum Beispiel die Polizei
die Möglichkeit haben in Unterkünften
wirklich komplett nach
abschiebekandidaten zu suchen bisher ist
die Regelung so dass man nur deren
konkretes Zimmer betreten darf und wenn
man sie deutlich vorfindet dann muss man
unverrichteter Dinge wieder gehen es
soll eine ständige Erreichbarkeit von
Behörden geben so dass man quasi rund um
die Uhr dort auch als Polizei z.B eine
Zusammenarbeit eine konkrete Abschiebung
organisieren können soll aber du hast es
gerade auch schon gesagt das sind
tatsächlich unter den Punkten die Scholz
eben übrigens auch vor der Frage der
Finanzierung dass er auch ganz
interessant angesprochen hat da war
vieles dabei dass schon längst
angeschoben werden sollte und wie wir im
Vorfeld dieser
Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz gehört
haben lesen konnten in den Papieren
überhaupt nicht wirklich in Gang kommen
und da sind auch Punkte drin da hat auch
die Bundesregierung relativ wenig
Einfluss drauf also Scholz hat eben drei
noch mal angesprochen das ist eine
Regelung innerhalb der EU wonach
Asylsuchende Flüchtlinge in dem Land
auch Asyl ihr asylgesucht Stellen sollen
bzw in dem Land bleiben sollen indem sie
ihr asylsuche gestellt haben
das betrifft natürlich Länder wie
Deutschland nicht in Deutschland ist für
Flüchtlinge gar nicht direkt zu
erreichen das sind dann Länder mit einer
Küste das ist vor allem Italien das ist
Griechenland das ist Spanien und weil
diese Regelung auch von Deutschland muss
man sagen als langfristig total
ungerecht
immer wieder ausgesetzt und natürlich
empfinden das gerade die Länder ich habe
es gerade gesagt Italien Griechenland
Spanien als ungerecht ob die da so
mitziehen da ist mein dickes
Fragezeichen dran zu setzen da wäre
diese da ist diese Regierung bei weitem
nicht die einzige die da jetzt dran will
und sie wäre nicht die erste also sie
ist nicht die erste die daran will und
sie wäre auch nicht die erste die daran
scheitert hat über die europäische
Dimension sprechen wir am Ende der
Sendung noch mit einem
Migrationsforscher an Dich Nicole noch
zum Schluss die Frage wir haben gehört
also in Sachen Kosten für die
Unterbringung von geflüchteten ist man
also von einer Grundsatzentscheidung
noch entfernt die wurde nicht getroffen
deiner Einschätzung nach wurde hier aber
ein langfristiger Plan grundsätzlich
beschlossen erfasst oder ist das mehr
jetzt wie so eine Projektarbeit die da
stattgefunden hat
man hat sich jetzt erstmal ganz klar
Zeit gekauft es gibt jetzt einen
Fahrplan das hat Hendrik wüst jetzt eben
nochmal skizziert im es gibt eine
Arbeitsgruppe eine Kommission die jetzt
einen langfristigen Plan möglichst
erarbeiten soll im Juni will man die
ersten Ergebnisse präsentieren und dann
im November bei einer regulären
Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz soll dann
weiter beraten werden
interessant ist was Olaf Scholz was der
Kanzler mit Blick auf diese Kommission
und die möglichen Ergebnisse gesagt hat
nämlich zweimal das Wort vielleicht das
heißt da ist noch ein ganz dickes
Fragezeichen daran was da überhaupt
erarbeitet wird und ob das dann auch
tatsächlich im November zu einer
Einigung kommt also wir können womöglich
vielleicht mit einer wieder langen
Kontroversen
Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz zu diesem
Thema im November rechnen dann hören wir
uns allerspätestens im November aber das
wird schon früher passieren Nicole
vielen Dank für die Einschätzung von dir
heute abend danke nach Berlin
sehr gerne
und wir können nun wir am Anfang in der
Sendung auch schon angekündigt hier
jetzt sprechen mit einem Landrat der
betroffen ist natürlich von dem ganzen
was wir jetzt gehört haben von natürlich
auch den Kosten die entstehen für die
Unterbringung und Integration von
geflüchteten es ist Christian Engelhardt
von der CDU er ist Landrat für den Kreis
Bergstraße und jetzt bei uns er sagt wir
sind am Limit hallo schönen guten Abend
Herr Engelhardt schönen guten Abend sie
haben mit uns zugehört die Beschlüsse
von Bund und Ländern sind sie damit
zufrieden mit dem was da beschlossen
wurde was sie da heute gehört haben naja
so wirklich begeistert kann man davon
nicht sein und wenn ich das vielleicht
auseinander trödeln dürfte zum einen bin
ich schon mal falsch dass die kommunale
Ebene gar nicht mit deinem Tisch saß das
heißt die kommunalen Spitzenverbände
oder andere kommunale Vertreter war
nicht dabei unabhängig davon ja über
etwas Geld über einem Jahr wurde
gesprochen und
einiges oder der größere Batzen der
Diskussion das Geld wurde vertagt für
mich ist aber Geld gar nicht so das
zentrale Thema da können wir gleich noch
mal sprechen warum es nicht das zentrale
Thema ist und ganz am Ende ist es glaube
ich für die Menschen im Land recht egal
ob etwas der Bund oder das Land durch
kommunenzahlen am Ende zahlt es eben der
Staat und meine Erfahrung die letzten
Krisen war am Ende wurde ihm auch eine
Einigung über das Geld gefunden zwischen
den verschiedenen staatlichen Ebenen
wichtiger sind für mich die Elemente des
Beschlusses die mit der mit dem
Flüchtlingsrecht zu tun haben also mit
der Frage werden tatsächlich Schritte
ergriffen um die Anzahl der geflüchteten
die zu uns kommen zu reduzieren und zwar
vor allem die Anzahl der geflüchteten zu
uns kommt die keine
bleiberecht-perspektive haben und da ist
mir das zu wenig zu wenig konkret ich
habe gerade versucht das Papier so nach
und nach zu verstehen durchzulesen das
ausgehandelt wurde ich will da mal ein
Beispiel nehmen zum Beispiel sollen die
Verfahren mit Blick auf Moldawien und
Georgien jetzt zunächst einmal
beschleunigt werden so steht es im
Papier das sind EU-Beitrittskandidaten
die beiden Staaten stehen bei uns nicht
in der Rangliste der Länder aus denen
die meisten Flüchtlinge kommen dann
stehen andere Staaten die beispielsweise
Türkei und die bleibe rechts-perspektive
in der Türkei ist relativ niedriger sie
schutzquote der Menschen hast du Türkei
zu uns kommen das sind die Länder bei
denen es wirklich
Ansatzpunkte gäbe die Verfahren anders
zu organisieren damit wir tatsächlich
weniger Menschen vor Ort haben die am
Ende keine Perspektive haben die
eigentlich zurückgeführt werden müssen
die teilweise erst nach jahrelangen
Verfahren zurückgeführt werden oder dann
eben trotzdem hier bleiben das ist das
wo ich glaube dass
tatkräftigeres und erkennbares und
konkreteres Handeln in dem Papier von
und man tatsächlich wichtig gewesen wäre
und ein letztes was vielleicht das ist
was mich am meisten
ein bisschen aufregt oder auch belustigt
ist der relativ große Teil der
Digitalisierung der Ausländerämter denn
diesen Papier ist und für die ja auch
ein Teil des Geldes ist also unser
Ausländeramt hat seine Akten
digitalisiert das erinnert mich an die
corona-pandemie dort wurde vom Bund mit
relativ viel öffentlicher Begleitung
eine Software für die Gesundheitsämter
eingeführt deutschlandweit die wir zum
Beispiel wie viele andere
Gesundheitsämter nie genutzt haben weil
die die wir bereits haben besser ist und
etwas ähnliches befürchte ich jetzt hier
mit Blick auf die Ausländerämter
außerdem sagen sie uns noch eine
einen Punkt aus sie hatten es eben
gesagt erklären Sie uns doch gerne kurz
warum ist Geld also nicht das zentrale
Thema nicht das zentrale Problem für sie
ja also wir haben viele Menschen hier
vor Ort ich will das mal ein Zahlen
festmachen letzten Jahr sind 4000
gekommen und
4000 Menschen das sind mehr als die
tritt kleinste Kommune unseres
Landkreises Landkreis ist ein wachsender
Landkreis das heißt
Infrastruktur ist eh schon stark genutzt
das heißt unsere Schulen sind voll
unsere Kindergärten sind voll Wohnraum
ist knapp und äh diese 4000 Menschen die
können wir schlichtweg so nicht
integrieren das heißt also
wir haben keine Chance sie auf absehbare
Zeit in
angemessene Unterkünfte zu bringen sie
sind in der Zeltstadt wie wir sie gerade
auch eingeblendet bekommen da kann kein
Integration stattfinden lässt die
Fachkräfte und zwar nicht weil wir keine
einstellen wollen sondern dass sie auf
dem Arbeitsmarkt nicht mehr verfügbar
sind in diese Integration durchzuführen
das ging ja eigentlich mit den Kindern
und muss bis zu einer erwachsenen gehen
wenn wir die Menschen die bei uns
bleiben integrieren wollen und das ist
alles keine Frage des Geldes sondern der
anderen Ressourcen wie Grund und Boden
und eben der potenziellen Fachkräfte und
deshalb ist meiner Ansicht nach der
Schlüssel für die Integration derer die
wir uns bleiben und das ist zwingend
wenn Sie bei uns bleiben ist dass wir
uns nicht um die kümmern müssen die
eigentlich keine Perspektive haben und
im Augenblick sind beide bei uns er war
Grund und Boden lassen sie uns da auch
gleich noch mal sprechen aber vielleicht
müssen wir auch erst verstehen wer alle
Userinnen und User alle die wir gerade
zusehen wie das funktioniert in
Deutschland überhaupt mit der Verteilung
denn es gibt hier bei uns eine Formel
sage ich mal einen Schlüssel nach der
geregelt wird welches Land also wie
viele Flüchtlinge aufnimmt und das hängt
mit der wirtschaftlichen
Leistungsfähigkeit der Länder zusammen
wir haben dazu einen Beitrag der uns das
mal erklärt können dann gleich darüber
sprechen einen Beitrag von Delia Thomas
Schutzsuchende die nach Deutschland
kommen werden über den sogenannten
Königsteiner Schlüssel auf die
Bundesländer verteilt dieser Schlüssel
berücksichtigt zu zwei Dritteln die
Steuereinnahmen und zu einem Drittel die
Bevölkerungszahl der Bundesländer
ermittelt so die wirtschaftliche
Leistungsfähigkeit und wird jedes Jahr
neu berechnet aus diesem Schlüssel
ergibt sich auch wie hoch der
prozentuale Anteil der Schutzsuchenden
ist die ein Bundesland aufnehmen soll
ausgehend von 100 Schutzsuchenden im
Jahr 2022 bedeutet das dass
bevölkerungsreichste Bundesland
Nordrhein-Westfalen hatte mit etwa 21 im
vergangenen Jahr die meisten Menschen
unterzubringen gefolgt von den
Bundesländern Bayern und
Baden-Württemberg die geringsten
Aufnahmen erfolgten in Bremen im
Saarland und Mecklenburg-Vorpommern
70% der Schutzsuchenden wurden von den
Bundesländern in Städten und deren
Umland untergebracht denn hier gibt es
gute Strukturen zur Aufnahme und
Integration Nachteil vielerorts der
angespannte Wohnungsmarkt
nur etwa 30 Prozent der Schutzsuchenden
wurden in ländlichen Bereich
untergebracht doch auch dort melden
Gemeinden Überforderung und die Sorge
vor gesellschaftlichen Konflikten
besonders wenn eine große Zahl
schutzsuchender auf einmal untergebracht
werden soll und das sind auch die
zentralen Kritikpunkte an der Verteilung
die Kapazitäten der Unterbringung die
Arbeitsmarktsituation und auch die
Möglichkeiten für schulische und
berufliche Bildung werden nicht genug
berücksichtigt
ein landratskollege von ihnen zwar
andere Parteien der SPD Thorsten Stolz
der hatte Schlagzeilen gemacht in den
letzten Wochen denn er hat das Land
Hessen verklagt weil er eben mit der
Verteilung von geflüchteten nicht
einverstanden ist so wie sie aktuell ist
wer das auch denkbar für Sie dass Sie
Ihr eigenes Land verklagen weil sie das
eben Unrecht finden
also ich würde das eigene Land nicht so
schnell verklagen denn ich weiß dass das
Land Hessen einfach nur die geflüchtete
weiter verteilt die ankommen die müssen
irgendwo untergebracht werden und der
Grund der Klage ist dass aus Sicht von
meinen Kollegen insbesondere die Stadt
Frankfurt und die Stadt Offenbach
anteilig zu wenig geflüchtete zugewiesen
bekommen was wünschenswert wäre dass das
Land in seinen erstaufnahmeeinrichtungen
wie geflüchtete die noch keinen Status
haben also die eben noch nicht
festgestellt bleiben berechtigt sind
zunächst dort zentral
unterbringt und uns nur die Menschen
zuweist die Bleiberecht perspektiv haben
das würde tatsächlich am meisten bringen
idealerweise sollte man das sogar schon
zuvor auf Bundesebene so machen
es gibt auch noch eine weiteren Zwist
also der Bund der verdächtig da auch
teilweise die Länder nicht alles an die
Kommunen weiterzuleiten es hieß Hessen
behalte viel Geld ein das sagte der
Präsident des hessischen Landkreises das
muss sie doch aber auch stören oder ja
also der Landkreistag ist in einer
Auseinandersetzung mit dem Bundesland
mit dem mit dem hessischen
Finanzminister darüber wie viel Geld wir
von den Bundesmitteln zu bekommen haben
aber die anfangs gesagt ganz am Ende ist
Geld hier eine Frage nicht das
entscheidendste in meiner Erfahrung in
der flüchtlingskrise 2015 damals war ich
bereits Landrat und noch eine
corona-krise war am Ende hat man sich
über die finanziellen Lasten
verständlich das war zum Teil längere
Diskussionen hat sich verständigt aber
ich möchte ja die Menschen integrieren
können und vor allem habe ich
Verantwortung für die Gesellschaft hier
vor Ort und ich sehe hier eine Grenze
der Leistungsfähigkeit erreicht eine
faktische Grenze der Leistungsfähigkeit
keine Grenze der Finanzierbarkeit ein
Problem was sie auch genannt haben ist
zu wenig Wohnraum aber wenn es zu wenig
Wohnraum gibt also auch zu wenig
Sozialwohnungen die natürlich auch
wichtig wären oder eben auch andere
Möglichkeiten der Unterbringung das geht
doch dann aber auch mit auf ihre Kappe
wenn es da von zu wenig gibt oder
ich glaube der Bericht den sie von
eingeblendet haben zeigt die Situation
wir haben dort zu wenig Wohnraum wo
Städte also in den dichter besiedelten
Gebieten es zu wenig Wohnraum in diesen
Gebieten gibt es aber auch große
Konflikte um Fläche also wir können
nicht einfach alles super Betonieren wir
können nicht einfach sagen jede Fläche
die noch da ist jeder Acker oder jede
Wiese jedes Gebiet das für Naturschutz
oder Landwirtschaft gebraucht wird
zukünftig zu Wohnraum gemacht in den
ländlichen Bereichen in denen noch mehr
Fläche da ist dort ist es schwierig
geflüchtete unterzubringen weil die
Infrastruktur so nicht er ist das da
gibt es dann weniger ÖPNV weniger
Angebote und das ist gerade natürlich
auch wichtig damit die geflüchteten
Menschen dort vor Ort andocken können
das ist eines der Themen deswegen ist
das nicht so einfach mit Wohnraum bei
uns fällt schlichtweg die Fläche um
weitere Wohnung zu bauen das ist ein
großes Thema bei uns seit Jahren unsere
Chef sich durch die geflüchteten
natürlich dramatisch denn zum Schluss
noch die Frage an Sie wenn Sie jetzt
noch eine Forderung formulieren könnten
denn im November oder Richtung Herbst
wird ja noch mal gesprochen was wäre das
eine ganz konkrete Forderung von ihnen
tatsächlich müssen die Maßnahmen zur
Reduktion der
geflüchteten bei uns schnell umgesetzt
werden und vor allem müssen schnell
Maßnahmen umgesetzt werden dass keine
Menschen ohne bleiberechtsperspektive
vor Ort ankommen das sind bei uns um
etwa 50% derer die uns zugewiesen werden
und das ist deswegen so wichtig weil die
Anzahl der Menschen die im Augenblick in
Deutschland ankommt steigt wir haben in
den ersten drei Monaten dieses Jahres
70% mehr geflüchtete wenn man die
Ukraine aus der Seite lässt also ein
Drittländern als im Vorjahres Quartal
und das zeigt dass die Entwicklung ihr
gegenläufig ist gegenüber dem was wir
uns wünschen würden
sagt Landrat Christian Engelhard CDU
Landrat für den Kreis Bergstraße in
Hessen vielen Dank dass Sie bei uns zu
Gast waren
es geht natürlich bei diesen
Entscheidungen wir haben heute so viel
über das Geld gesprochen eben nicht nur
über das Geld sondern es geht vor allem
um Menschen teilweise muss man natürlich
auch sagen Menschen leben wenn es darum
geht dass die Menschen die sich auf dem
Weg zu uns machen auf dem Weg nach
Europa machen da auch teilweise eben ihr
Leben verlieren hilfs und
Menschenrechtsorganisationen die sagen
Abschottung die Abschottung Europas die
funktionieren nicht die Festung Europas
dieser lebensgefährlich wir schauen mal
in einen Beitrag rein von wo diese
Menschen überhaupt natürlich zu uns
kommen und was das Ganze auch gefährlich
macht ein Beitrag von Petra Riffe
jeder zehnte geflüchtete auf der Welt
sucht den Weg nach Europa viele begeben
sich dabei auf gefährliche Fluchtrouten
um die EU-Außengrenzen zu erreichen
diese bringen es auf eine Länge von
50.000 Kilometern zum Vergleich das ist
etwas mehr als eine Erdung 80% der
EU-Grenzen liegen im oder am Wasser und
20% an Land
im westlichen Mittelmeer erreichen viele
Migranten über den Seeweg Spanien mehr
als die Hälfte von Westafrika aus die
beiden spanischen Exklaven sevita und
Melia in Marokko schützen ihre Grenzen
mit mächtigen Zäunen die gefährlichste
Route ist noch immer die zentrale
Mittelmeerroute in Holz und
Schlauchbooten versuchen die Menschen
über das Wasser nach Italien und damit
in die EU zu kommen mehrere tausend
haben dabei bereits ihr Leben verloren
die Dunkelziffer dürfte weitaus höher
sein
über Land versuchen geflüchtete aus
Ländern wie Syrien und Afghanistan den
Weg über die östlich gelegenen
balkanrouten nach Europa zu nehmen hier
meldet vor allem Griechenland dass die
Anzahl der angekommenen geflüchteten
seit dezember 2022 wieder heftig
ansteigt über die östliche EU-Grenze
sind im vergangenen Jahr vor allem
geflüchtete aus der Ukraine angekommen
mehr als 8 Millionen sind seit Ausbruch
des Krieges in Europa registriert worden
für sie gilt eine notfallregelung der EU
die sogenannte massenzustrom Richtlinie
heißt geflüchtete aus der Ukraine
genießen befristeten Schutz in der EU
ohne einen Asylantrag stellen zu müssen
sie konnten legal über Land einreisen
über die europäische Dimension ich habe
es angekündigt können wir jetzt sprechen
mit einem Experten mit Raphael Bossong
von der Stiftung Wissenschaft und
Politik er beschäftigt sich intensiv mit
dem Thema Grenzsicherung und den
Auswirkungen der Migration auf die EU
hallo schönen guten Abend Herr Song
hallo
Herr Bosson sie haben auch mit zugehört
haben jetzt also auch gehört was die
Bundesregierung davor hat also das was
da besprochen wurde mit Abschiebungen
die Asyl oder Asylverfahren die
beschleunigt werden sollen
abschiebeverfahren die beschleunigt
werden sollen war für Sie etwas dabei
was tatsächlich die Lage verändern würde
naja also diese ganze Thematik ist
wirklich ein
ineinandergreifenden verschiedenen
Maßnahmen und keine einzelne davon wird
wirklich eine große Wende herbeiführen
und auch zusammengenommen müssen wir uns
darauf einstellen dass der
Zustrom verschiedenster
migrationsformen auch anhalten wird also
eine Wende im engeren Sinne sollte man
sowieso nicht erwarten ich denke worum
es jetzt geht ist eine Perspektive zu
schaffen dass mehr Bewältigung schaffbar
ist auf eben neben der Kommunen aber
auch das natürlich innerhalb der Union
also in der Europäischen Union diese
Reform die jetzt bis Ende der nächsten
Legislaturperiode verabschiedet werden
sollen zumindest zum Teil auf dem Weg
gebracht werden und da ist ehrlich
gesagt nichts Neues dabei von dem was
wir schon auf eu-eben in den letzten
Monaten alles gehört haben und auch
dieses Reformpaket ist sie umstritten
also insofern denke ich kann man da
jetzt nicht von einem wirklich Neuansatz
sprechen aber der Tonfall der Regierung
im Guten oder im schlechten je nachdem
wie man es bewertet ist deutlich anders
geworden also es reiht sich eher ein in
die sagen wir mal Flüchtlingen
skeptische bis kritische Position viele
andere europäischer
nachbarschaftsstaaten wir haben einige
Fragen zur europäischen Dimension bei
uns im Stream eine kommt von dem User
jermain er möchte wissen inwiefern haben
zukünftige Entscheidungen in Deutschland
Einfluss auf europäische Konzepte zur
Bewältigung dieser großen Aufgabe
also natürlich hat Deutschland immer
einen Einfluss weil es natürlich immer
noch der größte Mitgliedstaat ist und
gerade in dieser Thematik besonders
zentral im Sinne der Aufnahme und der
Bedeutung für Asyl aber klar insgesamt
alleine kann Deutschland jetzt nicht das
Ruder umreißen in der Europäischen Union
und es bleibt ein Politikfeld wo und
zwar formell per Mehrheit entscheiden
könnte aber politisch sich alle bisher
darauf verständigt haben dass das
eigentlich nur um Konsens geht das heißt
also wenn
ein oder zwei oder drei Staaten eine
ganz harte Linie in eine Richtung
verfolgen dann war es bisher nicht
möglich diesen Widerstand wirklich zu
durchbrechen also man zeigt ja
normalerweise auf polnischen Ungarn aber
es gibt noch ein paar andere die auch
nie in diese Richtung gehen also
insofern weiß ich nicht ob Deutschland
da jetzt wirklich alleine deutlich
Umsteuern kann aber es ist natürlich
schon auch wichtig wie jetzt öffentlich
aufgetreten wird und wenn jetzt
Deutschland sich hinter das aktuelle
Reformpaket so wie es auf dem Tisch
liegt stellt das war in der aktuellen
Regierung noch nicht so offiziell der
Fall dann soll es noch mal ein Impuls
geben also wie gesagt man kann das
aktuelle Form Paket sehr kritisch sehen
aber das ist glaube ich der Versuch
jetzt der Bundesregierung dass man das
was jetzt da ist versucht abzuschließen
in den nächsten Monaten und das sollte
schon noch ein Impuls geben ja
es geht weitere Fragen der User Rudolf
spitz möchte gerne wissen kann man auch
andere Länder außerhalb der EU-Fragen ob
die die diese Länder Flüchtlinge
aufnehmen zum Beispiel Kanada fragt er
sich
das hat man auch schon gemacht also
insbesondere beim Ukrainern gab es oder
gibt es auch immer noch aber nicht mehr
so intensiv in der Anfangsphase eine
Koordination das humanitäre
aufnahmenprogramme laufen es sind ja
auch nicht unerhebliche zahlen nur keine
in die USA und Kanada
weitergeflogen das läuft grundsätzlich
auch mit dem UNHCR also es gibt ja jedes
Jahr so ein Prozess der Freiwillige
flüchtlingsübernahme aus Drittstaaten
und dann sollte eigentlich die gesamte
nationale Gemeinschaft sich daran
beteiligen aber die Zahlen sind
natürlich in dem Sinne viel zu gering
für die Bedarfe die es jeweils gibt also
das geht schon das ist ein Baustein aber
auch keine Wende jetzt im engeren Sinne
noch weitere Fragen von Sebastian dem
harter der User möchte gerne wissen
werden die Grenzkontrollen an deutschen
Grenzen erweitert und verstoße das nicht
aufgrund des schengender Abkommens gegen
geltendes Recht
ja also das ist sicherlich
ganz Probleme Sinne also ich würde auch
die Ansicht vertreten dass die
Binnengrenzkontrollen so wie sie
insbesondere gegen Österreich seit 2016
laufen eindeutig nicht mehr im
schenkenkodex gedeckt sind da kann man
natürlich dann immer versuchen zu tun
das sind immer neue Kontrollen mit neuen
Begründungen und dann laufen die Fristen
erneut an aber die Faktor ist es eine
Aussiedlung der maximal zwei Jahresfrist
die eigentlich vorgesehen ist
also ich kann nachvollziehen dass diese
politischen Forderungen nach
Grenzkontrollen da sind und dass man
damit auch versuchen will die
nachbarschaftsstaaten zu beeinflussen
weniger Menschen nach Deutschland
durchzuleiten aber das ist natürlich nur
im Endeffekt drei mehr oder weniger
Symbolpolitik um diesen politischen
Druck aufzubauen und nicht wirklich eine
Maßnahme die echt was ändert wenn man
jetzt in die Kommunikationen also die
Papiere da jetzt genauer reinschauen
muss man auch ein bisschen zwischen den
Zeilen lesen denn da steht nicht nur was
von präsenzkontrollen sondern auch was
von der Schleierfahndung und einem
Grenzregime mit Österreich also ich
glaube da gibt es so einen Grauzone die
auch versucht und auszunutzen dass man
versucht in der Grenzzone mit Polizei
Zusammenarbeit aber ohne Grenzkontrollen
mir eben abzufischen wenn das irgendwie
möglich ist ich habe vorhin im Stream
einen Kommentar eines Users oder einer
Userin gesehen der oder die schrieb mehr
Härte nach außen macht das besser also
ob das die Lösung ist stand da noch
Pünktchen Pünktchen Pünktchen was würden
Sie dazu sagen ist das eine Lösung ist
das vor allem auch eine humane Lösung
also noch mal Lösung ist es auf gar
keinen Fall und
nach außen sowieso also das heißt welche
Bedarfe in Europäer so ein Drittstaaten
sind die sind ja ungleich höher als hier
und da kann man glaube ich nicht sagen
dass werden wir härter sind dass dann
die Drittstaaten sich davon beeindrucken
lassen also das kann man glaube ich
schon in Jahren sehen wir kooperieren
mit Libyen und mit auch mit der Türkei
und anderen Staaten und also wenn in
Libyen jetzt schon noch immer Menschen
aufbrechen dann glaube ich wird es immer
nicht also da kann man ja nicht
abschrecken dadurch dass man hier ein
paar Leistungen einschränkt also das ist
glaube ich nicht das was was verändern
wird man braucht eher Partnerschaften um
dann wirklich eine bessere Kooperation
hinzubekommen die wird auch nicht über
Nacht kommen und wird auch nicht alles
ändern aber das ist das was eigentlich
gefragt ist innerhalb der Europäischen
Union ist es ein bisschen ambivalenter
also ich bin kein Freund davon zu sagen
jetzt muss mal Deutschland zeigen oder
Hammer hängt aber es ist natürlich schon
auch richtig dass
haben viele andere Nachbarstaaten so ein
bisschen da ausnutzen im Sinne ja wenn
wir eben nach unten schrauben und
weiterleiten dann wird sich Deutschland
schon bereit erklären und
zum gewissen Grad ist es natürlich auch
unvermeidlich wir wollen jetzt nicht den
Unterbietungswettbewerb mit Umgang oder
auch Dänemark anfangen aber trotzdem
kann man auch signalisieren wir brauchen
letztlich eine gemeinsame Lösung und es
kann ich alleine daran getan sein dass
eben diese anderen Staaten diesen
Unterbietungswettbewerb machen und das
ist zumindest die Hoffnung dieser
europäischen Reform wie gesagt sie sind
extrem umstritten und auch
menschenrechtlich problematisch also ich
will jetzt auf keinen Fall sagen das ist
der richtige Weg aber ich verstehe auch
die Bundesregierung wenn sie sagt sie
müssen jetzt ein bisschen mehr versuchen
auch diese Registrierung hinzubekommen
und auch ein bisschen mit allen Fehlern
dass es hat dieses Dublin System wieder
zum Funktionieren zu bekommen das ist
zumindest nachvollziehbar im Sinne der
innere europäischen Härte wenn man das
so nennen will der User David Sunday
fragt sich aber genau das also macht das
Dublin-Verfahren überhaupt noch sind
so wie es jetzt ist kaum die
verwaltungsaufwände für die letztlichen
Überstellungen sind ungleich im
Verhältnis also das kann man hat ja auch
Frau Merkel schon vorher gesagt dass das
System kaputt sei also es betrifft nur
ein gewissen Teil der hier Asylantrag
stellenden und dann von denen kommt nur
ein wirklich sehr kleiner Teil dann auch
tatsächlich in einen reales Dublin
Überstellungsverfahren
also die Logik von Dublin kann man immer
wieder kritisieren und das ist auch
wichtig dass man da noch mal drüber
nachdenkt ob man wirklich gegen den
Willen von geflüchteten sinnvoll die in
der Europäischen Union hier in der Daten
schieben kann es gab auch schon mal viel
bessere Vorschläge zumindest die
Beziehung der geflüchteten noch etwas
mehr als bisher zu berücksichtigen volle
Wahlfreiheit ist vielleicht lieber nur
keiner ein bisschen zu viel verlangt auf
politischer Ebene aber dass man mehr auf
Anreize setzt und nicht nur auf Zwang
das ist glaube ich das was wir brauchen
aber wir brauchen dann schon auch ein
System um eine gewisse europäische
Verteilung hinzubekommen und
verantwortungsteilung auch also insofern
gibt es halt nur letztlich wenig
Alternativen zu den Punkt wo man sagt
ein Staat muss zuständig sein und
natürlich müssen das dann auch manchmal
andere Staaten sein als Deutschland es
müssen nicht notwendigerweise die
Südstaaten sein aber dass man einen
Staat als für einer Asylantrag zuständig
bestimmt und dann auch nur einen und
nicht fünf so ein System braucht man
schon
Kommentare hier bei uns im Streams
schreibt Grenzschutz ist nicht die
Lösung wichtig ist extrem schnell es
Asylverfahren mit sofortiger Ausreise
wenn kein Asyl erteilt wird und
Abschiebung auch in Nachbarländer der
Ursprungsländer und Sabrina schreibt
Fachkräfte Fachkräfte fehlen da bringt
das Geld alle nicht so die Stimmung hier
bei uns im Stream an sie zum Schluss
sagen aber noch die Frage was wäre denn
ihrer Meinung nach eine funktionierende
eine humane Asylpolitik wo müssen wir
eigentlich hin was müsste getan werden
also ich kann ihn nur quasi die
kleineren Übel beschreiben leider im
Sinne das gibt jetzt Möglichkeiten
vielleicht ein paar der ganz schlimmen
Missstände relativ zu verbessern aber
gleichzeitig müssen wir auch sagen es
ist ein Politikfeld wo wir uns darauf
also das ist einfach so das ist ein
Thema mit dem wir uns langfristig
beschäftigen müssen und auch Deutschland
ist aufnahmefähig und auch andere
europäischen Leute Länder sind
aufnahmefähig und daran müssen wir
wieder hin dass wir diese Perspektive
haben denn was wir jetzt haben diese
wenn man das so nennen will und ich
finde es auch ein bisschen problematisch
diese Doppelbelastung also Ukraine plus
die sonstige asylmigration das ist auch
wenn es jetzt schon ein Jahr dauern
Krieg eine zeitweise Phase also
irgendwann mal wird auch in der Ukraine
vielleicht ein belastbarer Frieden da
sein dass wir vielleicht im nächsten
Jahr wenn es gut läuft der Fall und dann
werden auch vielleicht mehrere
hunderttausend wieder in die Ukraine
zurückgehen und dann haben wir wieder
auch wieder mehr Raum in
Anführungszeichen oder ganz wörtlich und
das wir wissen ja auch sehen das heißt
also wir können jetzt daran arbeiten
Dinge vielleicht zu verbessern auch ein
bisschen ja härter zu sein aber wir
müssen gleichzeitig eben diese Sicht
haben das ist eine lange Sache ist und
wir jetzt nicht aus der aktuellen Krise
Sachen bauen die für immer dauern
sollten das heißt wir haben jetzt die
Krise die müssen bewältigen und
langfristig müssen wir normaler
Asylverfahren gewährleisten und was wir
brauchen dafür ja wir brauchen zum Teil
schnellere Verfahren nicht unbedingt
Schnellverfahren wir brauchen dafür gute
Zusammenarbeit mit Drittstaaten vor
allem auch im Gegenzug für Legalisation
wir brauchen mehr Aufsicht in allen
EU-Staaten wir brauchen auch mehr
Monitoring was jetzt eben genau eben
pushbacks betrifft wir brauchen auch
nebenfrontext mehr Aufbau einer
europäischen Asylbehörde die
verschiedene Staaten unterstützt ja und
wir brauchen gleichzeitig natürlich dann
auch pragmatische Lösungen nicht einfach
sagen alle Asylbewerber können gleich
ein Spurwechsel machen wenn man das also
Lob sagt aber natürlich sowas wie du
Chancen Aufenthaltsrecht in Deutschland
ist sinnvoll dass man sagt nach einer
gewissen Weile gibt es auch diesen
Wechsel und das sollten auch andere
europäische Staaten hoffentlich mal
einsehen dass es in diese Richtung
weitergeht es sind mehrere Bausteine war
als auch noch nicht abschließend aber so
glaube ich kann man da hinkommen dass
man sagt wir können in Deutschland und
der Europäischen Union auch regulär
mehrere hunderttausend asylsuche in
einer einigermaßen geordneten Weise
bearbeiten ich denke das ist ein
realistisches Ziel
von der Stiftung Wissenschaft und
Politik vielen Dank dass Sie bei uns zu
Gast waren heute abend
und vielen Dank auch an euch natürlich
für eure Fragen und Kommentare für euch
noch ein Hinweis werden noch mehr zu
diesem Thema hören lesen möchte sei euch
gesagt dass heute journal von heute
Abend bei uns in der Mediathek hat ein
Interview mit dem Ministerpräsident von
Hessen Boris rein wir haben über den
Fall Hessen hier nämlich heute auch
schon gesprochen und auch ein Interview
mit dem Landrat der gegen das Land
Hessen geklagt hat für alle die das
interessiert schaut doch mal die
Mediathek in die Sendung von heute Abend
und für heute Abend war es das jetzt
auch von uns es war lang und schön dass
ihr dabei wart bis zum nächsten Mal
gerne wieder tschüss
[Musik]